is earthworld earthworm [ __ ] me
it's earth 2 a scam
hi my name is matt and you're watching
code tech tutorials
i'm a c-plus plus coder i want to take a
look
at this little thing that's been going
around this last week about earth 2
being a scam
i'm not invested in the game i've
watched a bunch of reaction videos
i'm aware that most of the big youtubers
are
criticizing it and saying it's scam
and so far from what i've watched it
looks like most of them are right
they've been able to kind of
tear apart any argument to say that it's
not a scam
so i want to just dig into some facts
and some
reactions and just give you my
perspective and let you know what i
think as a
non-invested third party
all right let's take a look
so they do have a web page it's just
earth
two dot io
and as you can see here it looks like
every land is up to wait 200
000 or more
and it looks like you gotta i don't know
they have some prices here
so quick synopsis from what i understand
of what this
is basically they're in development
they've got a team they've got a
marketplace and buy land
and they're in a land buying phase right
now so this is like
supposed to be a replica of the world
and they're doing a tile based system
and you can buy tiles uh and i guess
they're kind of comparing it to like a
crypto
like every land tile is a section that
can be
resold or whatever so based on location
might go up and down
so they're like oh you can buy in early
essentially someone will want the land
later and you can profit off of that so
i think
that's a pretty you know that's like a
pretty whatever system
okay it sounds like it can't
i i don't know i'm just gonna leave that
one alone for now that's just
i'm having a hard time wrapping my head
around why it would be a good idea to
buy into that that sounds like a
lose-lose situation already you know
you're buying digital land for a lot of
money
and there's nothing really to do with it
right now except
sell it i guess all right so we'll we'll
come back to that probably
uh let's just click some stuff and and
take a peek around let's buy land
so they've got a map here you can go
satellite
okay it's just an online thing okay
gotcha and i like the design of the web
page it's pretty clean
but they've got some highest net worths
they put a leaderboard up oh my
you know what they say about
leaderboards if you put a leaderboard up
someone's going to try to get to the top
and that scramble to the top is probably
making them tons of money right now holy
crap
so i guess the team behind it
you know they've got they've got a
pretty
i can't comment on the team you know
really you can read all about them here
looks like they've got seven developers
now the developers are the ones that are
supposed to be building this and they're
supposed to be like turning this into a
uh an mmo so i guess you know
what happens at that point is you get to
actually build on your land and play the
game with your land
um whatever that means is it going to be
like
we don't i guess we don't know and to be
honest
that big the whole world replicated
nothing's gonna run that well um
we need some extreme advancements in
computer science before
[Music]
that uh sort of scale is reasonable to
like
render but we'll get we'll come back to
that
all right this is gonna be like a pretty
long deep dive so
[Music]
we're gonna check out a few videos so i
hope you got your coffee i got a cold
coffee
and it's delicious
[Music]
all right so i'm like kind of taking my
time to think a lot here because
i'm trying to figure out
what to even say
so maybe the best thing to do here is
for for me to go look at
some stuff or show you some videos that
i watched and kind of react to them and
give my opinion
because there's not really a whole lot
here on this website so yeah you can you
can buy land
i'm sure once you log in and stuff it
probably
gets better
and they got a video okay
so footage was thrown together using
some works of prod
jazz from inside our e2 engine so
they're designing their own engine
okay we're gonna skip forward a little
we're gonna meet that i don't wanna so
this wait a second okay
this is something right now like you can
go look up youtube tutorials about how
to do this on
unreal or unity i'm pretty sure because
unreal supports this right now
so i don't as far as i know they're not
using unreal they're using their own e2
engine
but i know that you can do this and not
feel so i mean this looks good but like
but what is this is the question that i
heard come up
sure look looks cool cool terrain
but what i want to see is like you know
they could just throw this landscape
together
get this camera flying around take some
pictures but are they actually planning
on
using this so i think you know from a
development standpoint
if you want to do a real replica of the
world like they're doing
you pull the height maps from every tile
for this whole world
and you put them in here like this and
you can also maybe
if you can figure out where trees are
you can place trees and rocks and houses
so you could like sort of pseudo
populate things but it's going to look
super ugly unless you have really good
placement stuff it's not a task that's
feasible
you could do a hack job of it and it
would still be really cool
to just be like hey scan the world we
ran through this
we did the terrain uh however did the
height maps and
you know the different biomes it would
auto do those
you could you know it wouldn't be super
super hard to design a system like that
that just goes off all the height maps
and everything and the sea levels and
mountain ranges and whatever and just
auto kind of
does stuff so you could do the whole
world like that
like that's something i feel like if i
really thought about and had a plan
i could probably like hammer out a
little demo of that
in a day you know uh
but of course it's gonna take more
because anytime you say you're gonna
make something and it's gonna take you a
day it takes four times as long so it'd
probably take me like four days
but i don't feel like that's something
that's
uh not doable but also like here
is that what this is or is this just
like
hey here's like some landscapes and
shaders and stuff and a camera moving
around because that's all i'm seeing
and of course with music to make it
sound awesome
yeah this is like flying around terrain
this isn't that
there's nothing even close to
groundbreaking here this looks like
arma 2 or something or arma 3. you know
it's not
i don't know someone's going to be mad
about that
but like if people are being sold on
this
video don't don't be sold on that video
what that's
that's not like a there's nothing
there's game wise there's nothing there
you could like drop a character and walk
around but that's that's it like
i don't it's hard to say for sure all
right let's look at
some more juicy videos let's get into
some drama all right it's drama time
oh my goodness there's so many of these
guys this is like the thing to do right
now
and i wonder if people are just doing it
for clickbait
i mean it's great clickbait right now
you know i can't
can't go wrong i guess it's actually
really low according to whatever the
heck this little thing is
i want to find the juicy ones
i don't see any juicy ones all right
there's a few
in particular i'll find him and then all
okay here's the one i
originally watched it's from this big
fry guy he was
i watched some clips from a twitch
stream and it was actually really funny
hold on let's just like peek through
these because i think this is a good
place to start
because this is where i originally
learned this guy you know this is just a
guy that reviews fps's and
and new games and stuff he seems he
seems pretty legit like honest and stuff
you know he
doesn't hold back so earth 2
he reacted to it on stream and was just
like
yeah that's not possible and then
someone got really yeah i guess is the
one from the stream someone got really
mad
at him for like not doing his research
or something and jumped in discord with
him and it was the
i watched the whole thing it was so
funny
earth 2 supporter argues with me on
discord
like it's pretty cringy video to watch
but
just hear it in the earth 2 supporter
argue the guys
the supporter of earth 2 sounds like he
has a really
bad logical ability and it just kind of
made me
think it's even more of a scam that
people that aren't
the best logical thinkers are going to
fall for it
that's the hot take and there's there's
supposedly you're supposed to be able to
withdraw
draw your money but they don't have a
clean system set up so you gotta like
manually request and apparently you have
to spam them
and get in their discord and like talk
about it and eventually they'll
they're like manually doing payouts on
their whole system
when people want to pay out after
they've made profit or whatever
so it's really looking like an mlm like
more people buy in they get money they
can pay the people that are trying to
get out
as long as where people are coming
that's what it's seeming like i don't
know if it's necessarily that i don't
want to like
blatantly say it's that but that's like
what
most of these youtubers like this guy
and the others
seem to think and i'm kind of like
trying to
all right deep down inside i know i know
it's a scam obviously
because how would you it's uh the only
okay here's the reality of it right now
it's a scam
if they can actually pull this off they
can prove that hey we weren't
it wasn't a scam but the thing is this
isn't something you can pull off this is
beyond
our current technology sure you could do
a little
map thing online you can you know kind
of copy google maps
but to make a whole mmo out of it
is a whole other thing like that big of
a land is gonna be a server
nightmare uh
yeah it's just not i don't know what
they're planning on doing exactly
you know i guess you're supposed to be
able to build whatever you want on your
land
i i don't know there's no game yet
that's that's the thing
all right so there's another investor
reacts
hold on we gotta check this out we got
this is a this is
this is juicy material right here you
know big fry gets into it with this guy
but
we want to get into the mind of a
supporter you know
holy crap his videos
jeez okay so he dives back into it earth
2 is
this was the big one that got everyone's
attention well
6.2 k views i guess that's not
everyone's attention as you can see it's
only a six percent like ratio
i think that's because people from
bigger channels jumped on the bandwagon
and were like down vote this guy so it's
kind of like
he was kind of download bombed by that
so a little sympathy from that from like
you know
how bad would it suck to have creator
way bigger than you
say hey go attack this guy don't do that
you know
we're just doing research here but
that's kind of what happened
no he didn't they didn't bl i don't
think they blatantly said it but they
were really hating on him pretty hard
whenever one side of an argument this is
just a general thing
whenever one side of any argument starts
going
to personal attacks just nothing about
whatever's going on just like hey here's
some personal attacks like in the middle
of it
you know that they don't they no longer
are i don't know
it's like it makes them kind of lose the
argument even if they
even if they win they still lose kind of
thing in that way i feel like uh
this guy won and at least he kept his
head a little you know
he didn't fall into the trap of of that
okay i wanna give you a few highlights
here you can correct me if i'm wrong
but in this video here he like
he says he says he put in like five
thousand dollars i think
five thousand dollars of land and he
said he's pulled out
and got into his bank account like
about fifteen thousand i think i'm
saying that right
put in five thousand pulled out fifteen
thousand so in that case he made money
and if he actually like banked money on
this
then you know he's getting the last lap
he's like i don't care if he called her
scam or not
i'm doing great and but we're not sure
it was not clear
to everybody that that's the reality
because the problem is
like in this video
there is a lot of bias like
clearly uh this guy is wants to sell his
land on here
that's his main motive is to get you to
join use his link
buy some of his land so he gets more
money he's kind of like trying to
propagate
the whole thing so more people join so
he can make more money right
and you say well maybe he's not maybe
he's just making a video but
he pushes it pretty hard he says
somewhere in here he's like hey use my
link yada yada yada
it's not a scam it's not an mlm but use
my link joy
which kind of proves that it is so it's
uh kind of backs himself into a corner
there
by saying it's not a scam and then
pushing out the old
mlm technique like your friends from 10
years ago call you up and uh
try to get you with every once in a
while you know that sort of thing
i got this great thing and if you just
join you'll make tons of money all you
got to do is get a bunch of
other people to join under you and you
make tons of money because that's kind
of what this how this works apparently
if you buy
certain classes of these tiles or lands
you get like a
i guess sort of like an investment thing
you get a free kickback
but only when other people buy land
so other people have to buy land for you
to get this kickback
which uh you know that's not normally
how
if you've ever done anything with the
stock market or anything that stakes
you know that uh that's not how it works
you you just hold you have partial
ownership
and that sort of thing but we all know
in reality if you own land you just
gotta pay taxes
at least in my country so uh
by owning land sounds nice you still
gotta pay
every year on that land even
you know just taxes land tax so there's
no land tax apparently you
you're supposed to get the land tax or
something but only if other people are
spending money
so the fact that other people have to
spend money
all right well he's got a new video it's
not quite
as heavily watched and stuff so maybe
it's got some good context maybe we'll
just pull this this whole one
full one apart right here let's do it
all right
of course where i can give you extensive
knowledge on how you can make the lowest
approved
videos on youtube i will fly you
lowest approved video then you should go
to my studio where i will personally
train you
and you will go through a rigorous
course on how to upset
delicate snowflakes on youtube in record
time oh
i'm glad that he's taking this lightly
because geez
having a video is six percent only six
percent approval where he's pretty proud
i'm pretty i take my videos down when
they go below 80 sometimes
uh okay i digress for three easy
payments
of 99.95 what clearly he's just trolling
here okay let's get let's get back to
this a little bit
somewhere what's up what can you do with
this i don't know maybe we'll miss
something i don't want to skip it that's
a special thing this unique knowledge
well you want to be able to go to your
grocery store without getting spit on
or you'll get cussed out waiting for
your rental car at the airport and if
you're truly at the top of your class
you'll get the fbi calling you i hope
you know i'm joking don't send me money
okay so you know making light of the
situation's fine
but do people really do this no no one's
going to attack you
i mean if they do you can call the
police they can't do something
because if you do i'm just going to
start buying and wearing dislike
t-shirts but i swear i think that ratio
has got to be a record somewhere what's
up guy
nope probably not i mean it's pretty
good it's pretty good ratio as far as
downtown
steve here did this really just happen a
big fry tv
who was calling earth to a scam which is
not
now is signed up for something very
similar
to earth too like no joke it is called
uh paleo
i don't think philia is not similar to
earth too
i don't think also it's not out yet but
it has
a bigger better team behind it i believe
and
well i'm not trying to defend paleo or
anything but
it's not anything like earth too now
before i jump down my throat let's read
this paragraph together
the game is described as a community
simulation
mmo where you'll be able to build your
own town
collaborate with other players and
unravel the truth of your
mysterious past a lot of games do that
well the whole you know like you could
say that about any
a lot of different games like any of the
survival games where you work together
you build your own town that sort of
thing
but you don't the thing is the thing
people seem to skip over a lot is
you're not like putting money a ton of
money in
you like with palliative pay whatever
you say it
you probably just like pay whatever for
the game like 49.99
59.99 whatever you buy the game you have
the game
maybe there's a subscription or
something but but that's it
with earth 2 you're like
taking big money risks you're like
dumping part of your savings into it
hoping that it grows and thinking it's
your future stuff like that
with paleo or any other mmo there's no
illusion of that
you're perfectly aware that you're going
to spend lots of time on this game
and pay your 9.99 monthly fee and spend
lots of time on this game and that's it
that's that's the game
enjoy the game you don't you don't get
things
popping up at you and being like hey
this is untaken
you dropped 60 bucks here maybe you'll
get more than that later and here and
here and those are just everywhere
so you're tempted to keep putting money
in they don't that's the big difference
that's the big difference all right also
paleo is supposed to be a game it
doesn't look like her two's ever going
to be a game
it's fit i hope that it will it looks
super cool it sounds super cool but
the reality is it doesn't seem possible
and i get that you know people that
aren't super into development might not
realize that
and might think hey they got a good team
behind him seems possible seemed
plausible
and i could be wrong maybe it is maybe
they will get it done
but i would bank on no
right now i it doesn't seem possible all
right let's
let's listen let's continue this guy's
i'm i'm only at one minute nine seconds
in and
i can already tell you this guy does not
have his head on straight
he's comparing two things that are
anything really alike
well i think this is actually supposed
to be an mmo earth 2 is
like those it's massive
multiplayer oh gosh this guy thinks oh
yeah he's the one who said massive media
online rpg that's not what mmo stands
for
oh geez oh geez so maybe he thinks maybe
he still thinks that's what it stands
for i don't know
let's say that again community
simulation mmo where you'll be able to
build your own
town
big fry tv sign me up but seriously he
just like said that
earth what i'm confused now
does this guy really think they're like
the same game
and that they have the same premise of
staking land
number two is the same exact thing just
with
better graphics whoa whoa
better graph earth 2 doesn't even have
graphics let's be clear like
sure they're showing you pictures but
there's no you can't like go in this
game and run around there's nothing to
play right now
nothing zero they have these videos
which
anyone that has a little bit of
experience
on like unreal or unity can do this
without that much trouble
i would hope that a team of seven
seasoned developers could do
like something like this just make a
scene which they're doing clearly and
you know flying cameras around that's no
problem
that's not that big of a deal let's just
be clear here
there is no current game there's nothing
to install
so his arguments completely irrelevant
is this guy for real or is he trolling i
can't even tell i can't tell if he's
real
so because they added a monetary element
to their game now listen it's a scam
that's no that's not the reason it's
just the way it works right
it's like i just said you know you're
kind of being
constantly tempted to buy new land
thinking you're going to be able to
invest it and then also
for the investments to work you've got
to get more people to join
which is like that's classic mlm right
there
i should know my brother's been in one
or two
and uh eventually he realized he's not
anymore but
i remember when he was in him and he was
like talking to me about it i was like
man that sounds and yeah he
lost a lot uh doing that he he did not
make out well and he tried hard he put
in some work he was like
he was dedicated he's a dedicated
individual but
anyway i digress let's let's continue
see if we can get through this seriously
what is this disney
want to be a cinderella looking garbage
i'm
kidding i totally signed up but how does
this get people fired up but earth 2
doesn't
so you want to back
this guy doesn't get it all right
let's address that question so why does
this get people fired up
but earth 2 doesn't well i think we
figured out why earth 2 doesn't
i've already kind of touched that
there's not a whole lot more to say
but people are getting excited about
this because
well i don't know everything i i'm not a
big
i haven't signed up or anything like
that yet it's just that it seems
to have some stuff actually done like
this right here is probably
really the game and they probably have
some playable stuff
not just like scenes with cameras flying
around
and they're not trying to say hey fomo
fear of missing out you know join now
get this land cheap
or you can miss out and get it later
when it's really expensive
so they've got earth 2 has that fomo
thing going on
and that's like it's a sales technique
so if you're like
buying into the sales you could spend a
lot of money and if you're not good at
like
you know if you're a whale and you're
not good at controlling yourself and you
see something that looks
looks good to you looks spicy looks like
a good investment
and you just got tricked you could dump
like you know your life savings or
whatever into this thinking it's gonna
500x or 50 50 000 x
those numbers these numbers 129
000 times
uh value so people see this and they're
like whoa man i can make so much money
and they dump a lot in
that's the problem you ever heard the
saying if it looks too good to be true
then it probably is too good to be true
that's that's exactly
what's going on here this these numbers
right here
are so huge they look too good to be
true so they
probably are it's pretty pretty safe
i mean you know if a bunch of people if
i'm wrong and a bunch of people make
money off of this
like go them i'm not not against any of
that or anything i'm just trying to be
just trying to be straight here all
right let's continue
i'm still more what a minute 38 seconds
in and
i i'm still absolutely baffled by this
guy's sense of logic already
i mean i i don't mean to be like mean
but
i i guess i don't know if he's troll he
might be trolling is this the complete
troll video let's just watch i guess
like that because uh big names are
behind this i think
okay yeah i don't know all the names
behind this i heard like x blizzard devs
and x
league legends devs which is yeah
that sounds good for an mmo you want
people to have good experience
in the area the ceo of earth 2 actually
said pretty well
he said it right here i know they're
picking i'm picking on me because of my
background but at some point
in time every successful person was
unknown based on their approach only
rich and famous people should be allowed
to create
something new and inspiring meaning that
anyone else should perhaps not to try
wait a second no that's a that's a
rigged quote i mean
people don't think this there's
it's just that think of me for example
you've seen my recent videos
you've seen my maybe you've seen my
older videos if you look at like my
catalog of videos and kind of how i
progressed
you could take a pretty good guess at
what my next
few videos are going to be like it's
just like it's
it's that if you look at someone's
history of work you can kind of
take some pretty good estimated guesses
at what their next work is going to be
like and of course they're going to get
better over time
and it's great to practice and you know
me personally i'm rooting for anybody to
do new things try new things and succeed
uh especially when it's you know super
cool projects and all that and
i don't particularly care what your what
your past was as long as you're
dedicated and all that so
i just think that he's taking a little
hard maybe which
i get you know people are probably
really real in this guy
but like he really goes like pretty
patty's sad here which is where i lose
it based on their approach only rich and
famous people should be allowed to
create something
that's no that's not the point though
but i i don't know like i don't i
haven't looked enough in this guy's
history but
nor do i particularly want to it's just
that it's just kind of going down the
sadness realm perhaps they shouldn't
even try
that's never the answer like not trying
is the enemy
always try if you care you know
you don't want to try like things you
don't care about if you but if you care
about something
try you if you really care about
something you don't care what other
people say
right and maybe that's the case if
that's the case whether to and they
don't care about what other people say
then maybe they have a chance but
if they do care about what people say i
don't think they have much of a chance
because they're gonna get eaten alive
so they they really have to not care and
just
do what they are going to do and prove
everyone wrong
great something new and inspiring
meaning that anyone else
should perhaps not to try and unfair in
one of the developers i think it was him
i couldn't find the comment so maybe it
wasn't him but one of them said that uh
i'll be pissed if it's a scam because
i'm busting my ass over here
i think the clash in the recent okay but
that doesn't prove anything
it's a good quote but it doesn't prove
anything hey on earth too especially on
this
wait a second anybody could just say
that too like you don't know behind the
scenes if they're
they could just be like sitting around
doing nothing and then they just type
that you know
well i hope it's not a you don't know
you just don't know right
channel it's because a company is coming
out and putting
investing titans and neck beard basement
gamers into the same room
when they're usually worlds apart like
big fry tv
that's a gaming channel and then myself
i'm a financial
channel i know it doesn't seem like that
because of the nature of her too
but but that's what it is just powering
through
power through i'm here because there's
money to be made
and there we go there we go that's he's
here because there's money to be made
he's a financial channel he wants this
to succeed because if this succeeds
it's kind of like i was saying about his
earlier video if this succeeds
he succeeds if this fails he loses a lot
of money that's kind of
the underpin of what's going on here
that
that's my read there's money that i want
you guys to make you talk
money i want you guys to make you're
gonna have a really rough time
like okay well maybe you can all the
controversy with the withdrawals and
stuff
that's going on does not
make anything sound any better it sounds
like people are sometimes able to get
them
but they have to wait months and months
so that's that's an issue talk about
crypto
nfts uh earth i personally
everything i have invested in i could
pull it out anytime
whenever i want there's there's no
restrictions and i that's part of like
anything
i ever invest in i want to know the exit
strategy because you don't want to be
left
holding the bag you know you don't want
to be left holding
all the useless stuff man i don't think
i don't think there's a good exit
strategy here if everything flops
it's part of the problem to any other
meta verses like my last video got an
astounding
seven percent approval rating six
percent now it's even worse
but that's mostly because video gamers
are coming in
and telling investors how to invest you
don't seem
i don't think that's why i think he got
disliked bombed
from big fry's audience like obviously
clearly he doesn't like you
clearly he thinks you're full clearly he
told his audience that and they're doing
the same thing
i don't know it is what it is it's
youtube i mean busting open the the
doors of an operating room in a hospital
be like hey
hey hey doctor surgeon guy let me help
you with that or open heart surgery
there hey
like come on i've even said this in like
a past video actually one of my first
videos
how this is going to be so terrible
having these two worlds collide
i feel this channel is always going to
be controversial because the nature of
the piece and i know it's not my content
because i already got like 60 or 70
dislikes
before my my last video even premiered i
could have started that video
and said the sky was blue and giving you
400 reasons why it is
and it still would have been disliked
into oblivion um
aria okay i didn't care about this stuff
i just want to hear about the
actual game objection in one of his
latest
videos but this is the cryptocurrency
and the nft space
okay so i don't want to be in like i'm
interested in crypto and stuff but
i don't like these pump and dumper guys
i'd rather
i like i like natural stuff i like the
one you know
going with the natural flow of things i
don't like i don't like all this
fake exit strategy crap percent sales
spike and even the ceo
tweeted that and then big fry and others
are saying that
that's not because of them and it's from
this massive ad campaign that earth 2
started
and then he showed but yeah i mean if
they advertise on facebook they're going
to get
a lot of hits and twitter and stuff you
know all the big social media where
everybody
people of the world are it was what he
thinks is evidence
so i applaud him on that but what he did
what's wrong here is there's no evidence
either way
it's just like it's just all much
speculation it's like
where did the new sign ups come from i
don't know unless they have like a way
to prove where the clicks came from
it's all speculation probably so he
doesn't know is
this is useless information here that
that's just the renewal of some old
tv like just i don't even know what he's
talking about anymore renewing ads
old ads now maybe like hey hey what's
what are you talking about i don't care
about old days i actually watch this
company like every single day
and those ads have been there for months
don't believe me
go look at the comments under those ads
there are months and weeks old
so that's that's his proof that they're
not from the ads i mean
well you know if you expose
a lot of people to something some of
them are gonna click the thing
i don't know maybe they just wanted to
put in like 10 bucks and see what they
could do or something
because i would do that i would put in
10 bucks and see what i could do maybe
if
we're just playing around but a little
scared to put anything more than that
so no they didn't launch some like new
massive ad campaign
to be honest i'm not here to dismiss
their opinions like
all right this is not useful information
at all i don't know if i can continue
this this is
brutal i've lived in almost every state
in the u.s
wait what lived in almost every state in
the u.s
why hold on let's listen to this guy who
doesn't do anything to avoid this
situation
watch out for i think your hate is
misplaced i'm
37 years old and i have not once ever
been scammed in my life and i'm not just
what a clip to unpause to because you
know what everybody's saying right now
it's like until now right
i don't know if it's a scam or not all
right but if i had to guess
but if i had to cook just some boring
guy who doesn't do anything to avoid
these situations
i've lived in almost every state in the
u.s travel to several countries
and talk to hundreds of thousands of
people from all
walks of life drive a sixty thousand
dollar car and i'm semi retired
i pick stuff up here and there because i
get bored but that's not because of
any lack of money that's just because i
want to do something not to boast around
my successful life because that's not
really who i am
but i wouldn't get here if i just joined
scams like what
this this and that oh sign me up okay
well i guess the argument here is
we don't actually know and what does it
matter what
living in different states traveling
around the world and having a car
that costs 60 grand doesn't prove you're
successful and also i couldn't tell what
car that was it was that really a sixty
thousand dollar car it didn't it didn't
look like one it looked like a
i don't know just like an older lexus i
don't know i didn't know i'm not a car
guy i don't just join
companies off a whim that's not what i
do but
yeah in this last year it has been
really easy to make money in the stock
market and stuff so a lot of people can
say they're
super successful investors right now but
just wait you know we're having a repeat
i think this is just my own personal
take
i think we're kind of having a repeat
we're going to have a repeat of
what was the 1920s roaring 20s and we're
probably going to see a crash at the end
of this
decade so it's probably going to be
pretty big
that's my guess you know i'm not don't
take financial advice from me but
i just want to like look back at this
video in 10 years and see if i was right
i just have a really strong feeling
about that and i don't know why
it seems and a lot of times when i get
these weird really strong feelings about
things like that
they turn out to be true so take that
for what you will
i've kind of learned to trust my
instinct because there's so many things
ripped like no way yeah sure i thought
it but that doesn't mean it and then
later i've been like oh no i should have
committed i was
i was right but i didn't think i was
right okay yeah anyway
so that's a that's a nonsense point
let's continue
watching this guy i have not once ever
been scammed
i have not once ever been scammed you
know that's a lie there's not a single
person
that's 37 years old that has not once
been scanned
there's no way no way
i mean there's got there's got to be
something you know
not looking to start now and i don't
project that on this channel
there's no way i guarantee you that's a
lie
and and yeah sure the argument's gonna
be like do you have proof of course not
the proof is that's how you learn
you know like everybody gets scammed by
something at some point and then they
learn
to watch out for that stuff you know
when you're young and dumb that sort of
thing
but just to say
to try to save face and say i've never
been scammed a single time in my entire
life
that's another thing that just sounds
too good to be true
so you kind of know that like it's so
much fishy here
verve 2 was a scam why are they still
here six months later
who knows because they haven't left
what kind of question is that make tens
of millions of dollars already
and they regularly speak with the
community on discord
and they register and why would they
show their their registry or their
business number
probably because they have to i'll put
in this video
but if they want to disappear into the
night
well nobody knows what's going to happen
the point here is the whole setup system
is
looking pretty sketch and what they're
saying the game is is not very
feasible right now you know
like i said we need some serious
advancements in computer
science and hardware and a lot of things
if we want to see this game how they're
saying it is like you now you have two
governments chasing after you
you can't just say like no refunds
dissolve the companies peace out
no you can't yeah you can
it happens all the time sure i mean they
can't
they'll ruin all their reputations so
maybe it's not worth it for them to do
that
but once again i'm kind of seeing a
trend here of
of logical ability you just said you
can't do that
and that's you know that's a he's
applying a boolean
value and saying it's always one thing
when it's clearly not
all right well here's my program of mine
sneaking up on us but
that's that's a false statement no
matter how you
what you saying about government's
chasing after you you can't just say
like no refunds and dissolve the
companies peace out
no there's consumer protection laws that
sure they could do that it's not to say
that they couldn't
maybe they wouldn't that's a whole other
thing whether they would or not
but they could and that's not saying
it's a scam
that's not me saying it's a scam or
anything i'm just saying just kind of
picking apart his logic a little bit
because uh people can do whatever they
want you can't tell them
they can't you know they they could sure
perfect i could fly would i do
successfully no when i crash and burn
yes but i could fly so you can't say i
can't fly all right you know
that's not a good example but
people like if you disagree let's take a
tesla for example
oh god this this can't be good
you going to tesla right now tesla's not
in a good state right now you're aware
of that right like
elon musk is about to tank everything
because he's such a
whatever he is
he's such an um a troll i guess
like there's going to be a point when
people stop taking them seriously and i
think it's a turning point right
about now because he's kind of proven to
be a real
derp recently unfortunately but you know
maybe maybe he'll grow out of it or pass
it or whatever but
not looking good for him recently well
satan made like super
crappy cars and then with a whole bunch
of problems and then they just put in
their terms
uh if you don't like this car tough luck
your your your sol
then nobody would buy it what kind of
point is that
it was already a done deal you can't
you can't just say what if the past was
different
wait uh i don't even know i don't even
know
i'm not sure what his point is going to
be but it's definitely not going to make
sense
all right let's listen now do you really
think that elon musk would not catch any
heat for that like
the company would have never even gotten
off the ground
probably you know yeah that's what
happens people avoid the shady
the shady businessmen that's what's
going on here
that's common sense come on i think a
lot of people who aren't pro er to think
it's a scam
because they don't really understand the
mark they don't understand nfts or what
he even stands for
not that hard to figure out wait
you're railing on other people's
acronyms when
when you explained when it was last
video
oh god or virtual real estate in general
and to be honest if you're not really
tech finance or crypto like educated or
inclined
it's going to sound super scammy like
hey bro
yes it does sound super you want a ball
i can see that side it sounds like the
stupidest thing in the universe
but okay that's why i'm here that's what
i'm here for i'm gonna try to break it
down so it's like as easiest to digest
as possible
not doing a very good job and i will
never scam anybody
because what benefit do i get from
scamming
their money you get their money and
they're true
oh my god i can't is this real i was i
did not expect to
have this reaction i thought this was
going to be like
something different it hasn't been first
company that come out and like do this
idea
look up the central land yeah how good
the
how good the decentraland do still fake
land okay
and they have a smaller competitor to
earth a better feeling
me taking that down phone app that you
can put on your phone follow me on
instagram or twitter uh
wait he didn't plug his link this time
did he no he did he's got it down here
[Music]
holy crap look i don't know if
earth 2 is a scam or not it seems like
one but this guy is not doing it he's
not giving it any help
it's not making it look like less of a
scale all right well
i i think i've had enough um
jeez let me know if you guys want to see
more videos like this i'll be diving
into things like this
i'll see in the next
[Music]
[Music]
so
you